hey guys I'm Abby Shar welcome to Abby's
kitchen today we are enjoying the
outdoors we've got the bird singing and
the sun shining and we are going to get
grilling
in celebration of all our favorite dad's
for Father's Day now I know what you're
thinking when you read the title this
video vegan
Father's Day what the [ __ ] but let me
tell you these vegan burgers are so
delicious
they will impress even the biggest
carnivores in our dads so my dad is a
really big fan of vegetarian food so
even though he is not a vegan or
vegetarian at all I know that he's going
to adore these burgers so guys I can't
wait to get to it let's do this to a
bowl I mixed together some cooked quinoa
sweet onion puree black beans crushed
walnuts breadcrumbs garlic parsley some
tamari cumin chili powder black pepper
and salt and I put everything into the
food processor then I give it a good
whizz till it all comes together
transfer it back to a bowl then pack it
into some nice-sized patties place onto
a plate or baking sheet lined with a
Silpat and then transfer them to the
fridge for at least an hour to set up
meanwhile I preheat my grill to
medium-high heat and I give my buns a
nice little toasting
[Music]
once the burgers have set up in the
fridge nicely I pop them on the grill
and grill them for about five to seven
minutes per side
close the lid and let them cook all the
way through now it's time to assemble my
bun I had a layer of mustard some
pickles my vegan burger tomato slices
avocado microgreens some ketchup I put
it all together
enjoy so guys I hope you enjoyed this
recipe for my vegan burgers for Father's
Day if you did be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
some really great vegan recipes that
your dad actually is gonna eat subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
you
[Music]